[Musique]
lundi 22 janvier bienvenue dans le 78
sur tv78 voici les titres de cette
édition jusqu'au 14 mars les lycéens
peuvent formuler leur vœux d'orientation
sur la plateforme parcoursu pour les
aiguillers le salon de l'étudiant en
Eveline référence au célèbre magazine se
tenait samedi au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en yeline un territoire où
une multitude de formations sont
disponibles après le bac tour d'horizon
la mauvaise série pour les handballeuses
de Montini le Bretonneux samedi les
ivelinois se sont inclinés à domicile
2119 contre Harn une 4e défaites
consécutives qui fait plonger le club au
classement retour sur la rencontre et
sur les autres résultats du weekend dans
notre page dédié au sport aujourd'hui
nous fêtons la Saint-Vincent le patron
des vignerons est célébré partout en
France et notamment à Ben la commune
organisait des animations dédiées il y a
quelques jours et puis pendant un an les
collégiens de Charles pegy au chéner au
cancour ont rencontré des élus locaux et
nationaux des magistrats ainsi que des
ministres ces échanges seront au menu
d'un nouveau numéro de tribin demain sur
tv78 extrait dans les invités du 78 en
2è partie d'émission mais j'accueille
tout de suite sur ce plateau Nicolas
dandri bonsoir bonsoir de retour dans la
rédaction de tv78 trop bienvenue à vous
déjà vous nous rejoignez pour quelques
temps sur TV 78 on va faire le point
tout de suite avec vous sur les
informations du
jour et pour débuter Nicolas le procès
de l'attentat du super ru de trp s'est
ouvert ce jeudi ce lundi pardon il avait
notamment coûté la viis à Arnaud Beltram
un lieutenantconel de gendarmerie des
ivelines il a officié justement dans le
département effectivement grégoryi SEP
personnes comparaissent devant la cours
d'assise spéciale de Paris jusqu'au 23
février cinq prévenus au total seront
jugés pour association de malfaiteurs
terroristes criminels et deux autres
pour des délis connexes les fait on va
les rappeler hein le 23 mars 2018 un
attentat terroriste av visé
l'hypermarché SuperU de treb faisant
quatre victimes dont le lieutenant
colonel Arnaud Bertram Beltram pardon
l'océan officier des Yvelines avait pris
la place d'une notage dans le magasin
visé par l'attaque Arnaud Beltram avait
passé une partie de sa carrière dans les
Yvelines notamment au sein du groupement
blindé de gendarmerie mobile de
Versailles satori aujourd'hui une rue
porte son nom dans le quartier des
chantiers après la neige ça c'était la
semaine dernière c'est maintenant le
vent qui a semé la pagaille dans les
transports en commun oui grégoryi des
vents violents ont provoqué les chutes
d'arbres sur les voies résultat le
trafic du rerc entre versailleschantier
et Massie paszau a été fortement
fortement perturbé il a même été à
l'arrêt pendant plusieurs heures la
faute à la tempête Icha qui a balayé la
France cette nuit le département des
ivelines était placé en vigilance jaune
pour vent violent le trafic lui est
revenu à la normale dans le courant de
la matinée en 2026 les habitants de
porscheville et de Limet pourront
regarder la télévision on espère TV 78
grâce à de nouveaux panneaux solaires
voilà 18000 au total he c'est le nombre
de panneaux solaires qui seront
installés sur une dizaine d'hectares du
site EDF basé à porchecheville une
convention vient d'être signée entre la
Région Île-de-France et EDF pour
transformer l'édifice en ferme
photovoltaïque ces panneaux vont
alimenter en électricité les communes de
Limet et Porcheville et vous l'avez dit
ils produiront 10 MW soit l'équivalent
de la consommation annuelle de près de
6400 foyers les travaux devraient
débuter à la fin de l'année 2025 pour
une mise en service l'année suivante une
vigilance à présent depuis le début de
l'année une nouvelle arnaque Séville en
île-de-fance notamment dans les ivelines
attention aux imposteurs Grégory depuis
le début de l'année les brigades de
gendarmerie d'Île-de-France constatent
une recru d'esence des vols à la fausse
qualité autrement dit des délinquants se
font passer pour des faux policiers ou
des faux gendarmes vêtus de brassard et
parfois d'une fausse carte
professionnelle ces délinquants font
croire et bien aux habitants qu'une
série de cambriolages touche leur
quartier et qu'ils doivent faire ben le
tour de leurs habitations profitant et
ben parfois de la naïveté des habitants
pour et bien voler ou dérober et
préparer peut-être de cambriolage alors
il y a il y a quelques conseils
justement pour lutter contre ces ces
cambriolage effectivement d'abord de ne
jamais laisser une personne inconnue
seule dans une pièce de votre habitation
et puis le deuxième conseil qu'on peut
vous donner c'est de contacter les
forces de l'ordre pour vérifier auprès
de l'administration concernée la
présence d'un de ses agents sur le
terrain et on finit avec cette
information la SPA a publié son bilan de
l'année dernière 2023 il y a du bon et
du moins bon moins d'abandon moins
d'adoption voilà le bilan et le premier
constat qu'on peut faire du bilan 2023
de laasa en terme de chiffre 9565
animaux ont été pris en charge en
Île-de-France par les six refruge de la
SPA basée dans les Evelin alors on
retrouve Hermeray orjeval et plaisir
dans les Evelin c'est 2 % de moins qu'en
2022 néanmoins l'association dé nombre
8643 adoptions soit 7 % de moins qu'en
2022 un chiffre qui explique pourquoi
les refuges restent saturés merci
Nicolas et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous voyez une
actualité qui vous fait réagir dans les
evelines n'hésitez pas à la partager sur
les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78 new et dans l'actualité
également c'est ouvert depuis la semaine
dernière les lycéens ont jusqu'au 14
mars pour formuler leur vœux
d'orientation sur la plateforme parcours
su sur le territoire de 50 an Eveline
beaucoup de possibilités existent pour
poursuivre ces études après le bac les
jeunes ont pu les découvrir à l'occasion
du Salon de l'étudiant en ielin c'était
samedi dernier du côté du Vélodrome
national de 50 ans nelin le reportage de
Gabriel Gontier et de Jen Julien Leroi
commerce ingénierie ou encore
agriculture choisir son orientation est
souvent synonyme de stress alors pour
accompagner les lycéens le salon de
l'étudiant a fait son grand retour au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
après l'ouverture de parcours suple le
17 janvier dernier étudiants et parents
étaient nombreux à venir découvrir les
formations salon principalement permet
aux étudiants et leurs parents de
s'informer d'être en contact direct avec
les écoles et donc du coup de pouvoir
avoir les conseils et d'être le mieux
aiguillé pour donc faire leur vœux par
la suite et choisir leur formation
postbac parmi les 70 exposants 40
établissements de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline c'est le cas de l'école
supérieure des agricultures de Guy
encour dont les formations attirent les
étudiants ce qui est bien c'est qu'on a
deux autres cycles qui sont moins
rapides bachel ça va être 3 ans alors ce
sera il y aura toujours du concret mais
il y aura un peu plus de théorique cette
fois-ci ça reste des métiers assez
importants c'est quand même la base de
la survie d'une société l'agriculture on
en a tous besoin et surtout dans le
contexte actuel contexte économique et
surtout le contexte environnemental s'il
y a bien un truc que j'ai remarqué au au
sein de la jeunesse en tout cas des gens
de mon âge à peu près c'est qu'il y a un
engouement qui se crée plus ou moins
autour du côté environnemental et pour
ceux qui se tourneraient vers le public
une université celle de Versailles
SaintQuentin en Yveline membre de Paris
saclé on est quand même la seule
université présente ici les autres c'est
des des écoles privées plus ou moins
donc on représente un peu le secteur
public aussi une diversité de formation
qui a attiré plus de 4000 étudiants
étaient présents cette année je suis
déjà venue il y a 2 ans et oui en vrai
on retrouve assez d'information et bah
il y a beaucoup de volontaires qui
répondent à nos à nos questions des
réponses auxquelles il faudra répondre
avant le 14 mars pour les formations
publique date de clôture de formulation
des vux sur parcours sup allez c'est
l'heure des actualités sportif dans le
[Musique]
78 et c'est avec vous Nicolas d'andr on
commence avec du basket et une bonne
nouvelle pour Victor wembanama 8e succès
cette saison en NBA pour les Spurs de
San Antonio alors tout ça sur 42 matchs
au total hein donc vous voyez très peu
de succès pour Victor wembadiama et ses
coéquipiers qui se sont imposé et bien
131 à 127 contre les Wizards de
Washington c'était dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche classement de la
Conférence Ouest saintantonio reste à la
dernière place le prodige versaillais a
encore brillé sur les parquets
américains Grégory Victor wanama a
notamment terminé meilleur marqueur de
la rencontre avec 24 points et en
défense il est redoutable il a terminé
avec 8 rebonds et six contre il ne finit
pas de nous surprendre le Dakar 2024 ça
s'est conclu ce weekend avec la victoire
de Carlos sain je parle pas de Carlos sa
junior en Formule 1 mais bien de Carlos
sa Carlos SAES le pilote espagnol de 61
ans qui emportter sa 4e victoire sur la
course mythique du Dakar une catégorie
dans laquelle concourait aussi un
ivelinois c'était le doyen de l'édition
2024 à 77 ans Jean-Pierre strugot a été
contraint d'abandonner juste avant la
12e et dernière étape malheureusement le
pilote originaire de Chatou a terminé la
11e 11e étape à la 142e place et à la
129e place au classement général mais
bien sûr son résultat n'a pas été pris
en compte puisqu'il n'a pas terminé
l'édition du Dakar on voyage dans les
actualités sportives on était aux
États-Unis en Arabie Saoudite on va
quitter l'Arabie Saoudite pour revenir
dans lesblines avec du handball et une
nouvelle défaite malheureusement pour
les féminines en handball c'est à
montinil Bretonneux ouais une mauvaise
série de quatre défaites en quatre
matchs qui se poursuit Grégory les
unontaines se sont inclinés 19 à 21
contre ARN ce samedi 20 janvier lors de
la 14e journée de National 2 à la salle
alin Colas de Montin Bretonneux retour
sur cette rencontre avec un montage
signé ludovicque
[Musique]
Leni la se poursuit pour Montini le
brotonneux quatre défaites consécutives
les handballeuses ini Montaine se sont
inclinés à domicile 21 à 19 contre Harne
l'équipe avant-dernière au classement de
la Nationale 2 à deux places du club
cinquantinois je pense qu'on s'est dit
qu'elle c'était dans les dernières donc
on allait gagner je pense que
psychologiquement on s'est pas mise
dedans et donc sur le match on était non
chalente on était lente on pourit pas
assez on s'était vite fatigué et du coup
perte de balle sur perte de balle pas
d'efficacité au tir donc on a eu
beaucoup de de tirs manqués c'est une
équipe qui sens plus faible voilà on
mène quasiment tout le match et on se
fait dépasser sur quelques minutes
malheureusement les les minutes
essentielles l'excès de confiance
contraste avec les derniers résultats
Montini le Bretonneux n'a plus gagné
depuis le 18 novembre 2023 résultat les
in monontain pointent à la 9e place
j'espère redresser la barre assez
rapidement cette début d'année là pour
essayer de maintenir et de pouvoir faire
une allnée belle potentiellement avec
une montée l'année prochaine et ça
commencera lors de la 15e journée
Montini le Bretonneux se déplacera à
Tessi le 10 février un adversaire direct
au classement une victoire permettrait
au cinquantinoise de se
relancer bon là cétait dans un gymnase à
l'extérieur on avait encore des terrains
enneigés ce weekend résultat Nicolas
plusieurs matchs annulés notamment rugby
ouis effectivement dans les Evelin il y
avait beaucoup de matchs au programme et
puis il y en a plusieurs qui ont ont été
annulé notamment en fédéral 2 le très
attendu derby yvelinois entre plaisir et
Versailles a été reporté tout comme le
match entre MLSGP et oxer en revanche
ben alors en fédéral 3 d'abord monté son
Chatou n'a pas effectué son déplacement
à Vincen donc l'Est parisien a aussi été
touché en revance chose surprenante un
match de rugby qui s'est tenu à
SaintQuentin en Yveline en régional une
l'Union rugby centre 78 s incliné d'un
tout petit point face à momoran si soisi
pour cette 12e journée du championnat au
classement de la poule 2 l'URC 78 occupe
la dernière place avec une seule
victoire depuis le début de la saison on
va le voir au classement l'URC avec
seulement 6 points dernière place pour
l'URC autre rendez-vous sportif ce
weekend au clé sousbois où avvez lieu le
le championnat les championnats
départementaux de karaté d oui
effectivement au programme karaté kata
et combat individuel et par équipe la
compétition avait lieu au gymnase
Guimier et s'il n'y avait pas de grands
enjeux ce weekend tous les car Ateka
étant déjà qualifié pour les
championnats d'Île-de-France la
compétition a permis d'avoir un aperçu
du niveau des licenciés ivelinois on
écoute le président du Comité
Départemental au micro de Gabriel
Gontier les evelines sont le plus gros
département de France en terme de
licencier le niveau est très bon on a
des athlètes qui sont qui qui quandme
qui qui performment sur les compétitions
sur les coupes de France et les
championnats de France sont pas
forcément sur les podiums mais sont au
pied du podium donc ça veut dire que le
niveau est très très élevé alors avec
plus de 9000 licencié dans le
département cette art martiale attire de
plus en plus de sportifs licenciés
notamment de par ses valeurs il y a de
la convivialité quand on vient en
compétition on sait qu'on va retrouver
les copains vont par que ce soit du
département ou dans la France entière ça
permet aussi de se sociabiliser
d'apendre à connaître de nouvelles
personnes et ça je trouve que c'est
important aussi c'est un Super Sport
plein de respect plein de belles valeurs
c'est un sport de combat ça permet de se
défouler se dépenser et surtout c'est
dépassé on rentre à la maison le soir
qu'on est perdu qu'on a gagné on est
fier de soi donc franchement
c'est un Super Sport fait pour tout le
monde et il faut se lancer un
rendez-vous à noter grégoryi pour les
ivelinois et bien ce sera les
championnat d'île-de-fance le 4 février
prochain à ringis on souhaite bien sûr
bonne chance aux ivelinois qui seront
engagés sur ces championnats en termine
de ces informations sport avec un bout
de football ouais bonne chance aussi au
versaillais ce soir en Nationale qui
vont jouer et bien face à martig un
match prévu à 19h dans le cadre de la
18e journée avec un match en retard les
Versaillais pointent à la 11e place au
classement ce soir les hommes de la cité
royale affrontent les Provençaux qui
sont 4e du championnat avec 29 points et
un match en retard donc on précise que
versaill est 11e sur un classement avec
18 équipes au total dans ce championnat
national où il y a quand même six
équipes qui descendent à la fin de la
saison à partir de la 13e place on est
déjà reléable on souhaite bonne chance
au versaill merci Nicolas pour toutes
ces informations
sportives tous les 22 janvier nous
célébrons la Saint-Vincent le patron des
vignerons à Ben tous les 5 ans des
festivités sont organisées pour
l'occasion la 3e édition de la
Saint-Vincent s'est déroulée il y a
quelques jours dans la commune dans le
pur respect de la tradition
bourguignonne Clara de Frutos et
Mathilde
Francou le patron des vignerons a été
célébré dans le respect de la tradition
bourguignonne tous les 5 ans
l'association des vignerons de Ben
organise la Saint-Vincent fêté le 22
janvier le monde viticol se rassemble
pour prier chanter défiler honorer les
anciens et surtout faire la fête le
Saint-Vincent est le patron des
vignerons
euh donc la Saint-Vincent nous on
l'organise tous les 5 ans parce que on n
quand même pas dans un pays de vignoble
encore mais euh dans les pays euh de vin
de notamment Chablisien c'est organisé
donc la tous les ans onappelle une
Saint-Vincent tournante qui qui regroupe
les 20 communes du du
Chablisien vêtus de leur tenue
traditionnelle une dizaine de membres de
la confrerie des piliers chablisiens
étaient présents pour honorer le patron
des vignerons comme nous sommes un
vignoble producteur de vin blanc donc il
fallait des couleurs qui représentent le
fameux breuvage que nous nous produisons
tous les ans et donc le Chael c'est un
vin blanc avec des couleur or et des
reflets verts c'est pour ça que nous
avons une Nabe couleur or avec un
surplis vert ça c'est un cordon notre
cordon toujours aux couleurs de notre
vignoble c'est les armes de chabel de la
ville de chabel voilà donc le tast vin
c'est le symbole de la dégustation de la
Bourgogne comme le veut la tradition
plusieurs amateurs de vin ont été
intronisés pour intégrer la confréie
pour pouvoir être choisi les candidats
du jour devaent passer l'épreuve
obligatoire la dégustation de vin de
chabl pour Martine et Nadine nouvelle
intronisé c'est la surprise grosse
surprise puisque on ne connaît pas le
nom des intronisés à l'avance donc
grosse surprise en fait et puis bah bel
honneur ça a été une surprise et comme
je suis membre de l'Association des
viges rond ben depuis de nombreuses
années cette reconnaissance m'a beaucoup
touché dans 5 ans la ville de Ben fêtera
sa 4e Saint-Vincent toujours avec
modération avant les invités du 78 coup
d'œil aux prévisions météo de
demain une journée plutôt morose dans
votre matinée de mardi dans les yvines
avec de la pluie hein dès le matin côté
température ça revient des normales de
saison compte 5°gr à rambbouillet 6 sur
le reste du territoire dans l'après-midi
toujours de la pluie il fera 10°gr dans
toute la moitié nord des ivelines 9°gr
au sud vigilance le vent soufflera fort
par endroit jusqu'à 50 km/h et ce mardi
23 janvier
nous fêterons non pas les Bernards mais
les barnards tout de suite les invités
du
[Musique]
78 marqué par l'assassina du professeur
Samuel paaty Solen de la rooc parent
d'élèves au collège Charles pegy du
chéner au cancour a lancé une grande
opération son but faire connaître les
valeurs citoyennes et républicaines au
collégien pendant un an les élèves ont
pu rencontrer des élus locaux ou
nationaux des magistrats ainsi que des
ministres Julien Leroi les a suivi pour
tv78 dans cet extrait il raconte à
Patrice carmous le rencontre avec yail
Bron Pivet la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et Gérard Larchet le président
du Sénat alors on a vu Béatrice Piron là
avec émotion quand elle découvre
l'Assemblée nationale mais vous vous
l'avez découverte aussi l'Assemblée
nationale et pas n'importe où puisque
vous avez raccontré la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale euh oui je
m'appelle Théo exactement on a vu madame
miel elle BR pivé du coup on l'a
beaucoup interrogé on a eu que 30
minutes c'est dommage mais on a pu lui
poser des questions intéressante et elle
nous a répondu et à la fin on a pu bah
regarder comment ça se passait à
l'Assemblée nationale et ce qui se
passait oui vous avez assisté à une
séance oui est-ce que mais est-ce que ça
vous a impressionné de rentrer à
l'Assemblée Quentin oui oui on était
très content de rentrer à l'Assemblée
voilà ça fait ça fait une petite émotion
quand même et aussi ce qui nous a
frapper c'est l'importance qu'a bah la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale au
sein même de de l'Assemblée nationale
sur la distribution de parole entre les
différents députés et notamment il a le
Bron pivé a fait très fort car c'est la
première femme à être présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale donc une belle
victoire pour la France bravo alors il y
a il y a une chose qui vous a frappé sur
laquelle vous l'avez beaucoup
interroger on voit qu'en classe parfois
il y a des il y a du Chahu à l'Assemblée
il y en a drôlement
oui du coup bonjour je m'appelle Sam
Samia du coup euh oui on a vu du coup on
assistait à une séance durant bah quand
on était à l'Assemblée nationale et on a
pu voir du coup l'opposition qu' avait
entre certains députés euh ce qui était
assez bah choquant parce que on se dit
comme ça nous on a les lois et après le
fait de voir comment sont voter comment
débattre comment débattre du coup les
députés ça a été très très intéressant
du coup est-ce que vous dites si si ces
gens-l qui sont élus qui sont députés
arrivent pas à rester SAG pourquoi nous
qui sommes des élèves du collège on le
serait ben enfin en fait c'est un peu
des députés donc je pense queils avaient
faut qu'il débattent ensemble et
doncin c'est important qu'il qu'ils
expriment ce qu'ils pensent même
fortement oui et donc c'est pour ça que
c'était peut-être un peu dynamique mais
je pense c'est un peu normal et ben
justement Bron pivé dans la rencontre
que vous avez eu avec elle elle explique
que bah s'il y a des débats un peu
virulents un peu violents et ben c'est
un signe au f de la de la vie
démocratique justement ça n'est pas
représentatif de ce qui se passe tous
les jours en séance il y a des moments
où effectivement il y a du Chahu mais la
plupart du temps les débats se passent
bien sont respectueux et se déroulent
dans le calme pour autant qu'il y ait du
Chahu c'est la suite logique de du choix
des Français les Français ont choisi
deslires des personnes pour les
représenter qui représentent tous les
groupes politiques même les plus
extrêmes et donc il est normal que
lorsque ces groupes politiques se
retrouvent dans une même enceinte pour
débattre de sujets qui sont importants
il est normal qu'il y ait de la
controverse qu'il n'apprécient pas les
déclarations de l'autre que le ton monte
c'est ça la vie démocratique j'imagine
que vous dans vos organes dans vos
conseils dans vos classes parfois vous
n'êtes pas d'accord le temps monte et
cetera c'est normal maintenant ce qui
est important c'est que ce soit fait
quand même même dans le respect qu'on
n'insulte pas les gens on ne s'injurie
pas on en vient pas au main enfin il
faut qu'il y ait des règles et à
l'Assemblée national il y a un règlement
et moi je suis chargé avec mes
vice-présidents de le faire respecter on
vient de voir votre entretien avec Hel
brun pivé qui est la première femme
comme disait Quentin présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et puis vous avez
rencontré aussi quelqu'un qui est très
important c'est le deuxè personnage du
du de de la République c'est le
président du
sénatché d'abord est-ce que vous saviez
quelle était la différence en gros entre
le Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale entre
les sénateurs et les députés euh non
enfin globalement on pensait que bah
sénateur et députés c'était à peu près
la même chose et c'était juste deux
chambres qui se partageaient les lois et
qu' les voté ensemble avec entente et
c'était pas si différent l' pas si
différent c'est pas tout à fait
différent d'ailleurs tu raison le Sénat
et l'Assemblée vote les vote les lois
qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué che chez le
président du
Sénat alors tout d'abord bah on a été on
a eu vraiment beaucoup de chance de
pouvoir l'avoir rencontré donc c'est pas
c'est pas donné à tous les élèves de
toute la France il est venu ici oui
exactement donc bah on l'a interviewé
et content bah on est on était content
de qu'il vienneent pour qu'il nous
exprime ses ses valeurs de la République
notamment sur le golisme et euh
oui je pense c'était une belle
expérience et euh je pense que certains
d'entre nous savaient global enfin
avaent une petite idée de la différence
entre députés et sénateurs les députés
ils sont élus bah par des par des des
citoyens dans une circonscription et les
sénateurs ils sont élus par des maire
voilà 2e degré part desjà des gens qui
sont qui sont qui ont des fonction poli
euh vous vous lui avez parlé de la
suppression du Sénat pas mis en colère
non mais il trouvait ça dommage et que
c'était important pour lui que le Sénat
existe et je pense aussi parce que c'est
d'après ce qu' nous d'après ce qu'il
nous a dit c'est beaucoup moins mitigé
au Sénat qu'à l'Assemblée nationale donc
peut-être que le Sénat est important et
peut trancher facilement les les débats
oui le travail pas est pas le même tout
à
faitassemblée au sénre spectaculaire
mais il y a peut-être plus de travail de
fond au Sénat en tout cas bah Gérard
Larcher explique dans l'entretien qu'il
vous a accordé combien le le Sénat est
important pour la préservation de nos
libertés Collectiv et individuelle je
pense d'abord pour poser la question
pourquoi de chambre on l'a dit tout à
l'heure pour stabiliser pour se donner
le temps de la lecture pour
avoir une
représentation de parlementaires qui
sont issus de électoraux différents
quand vous allez avoir 18 ans vous allez
pouvoir voter pour les
députés mais vous pourrez pas voter pour
les sénateurs il faut attendre d'être
conseiller municipal du chaîner auancour
par exemple pour voter pour les
sénateurs donc un mode de scrutin
différent une représentation différente
et donc une capacité à éviter de tomber
dans les excès
et je dois dire que ceux qui sont pour
le
monocamérisme c'est parce qu'en fait ils
ont le sentiment que c'est le Sénat
parfois complexifie les choses parce
qu'il est surtout très attentif aux
libertés individuelles et
collective et vous pourrez retrouver
l'intégralité de ces rencontres dès
demain dans l'émission tribin sur tv78
voilà c'est la fin du 78 merci de votre
fidélité on se retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée sur
tv78
[Musique]